Anche se i computer quantistici non saranno adatti a risolvere
tutti i problemi, ci sono alcune classi di problemi
e potenziali casi d'uso in cui ci aspettiamo
che il quantum computing abbia un impatto.
Questi includono la simulazione, come
la modellazione di processi e sistemi che si verificano in
natura, la ricerca e l'ottimizzazione,
che comportano la ricerca della soluzione migliore o
ottimale in una situazione con
molte possibili risposte, e la matematica
e l'elaborazione di dati con struttura complessa,
incluse applicazioni per il machine learning.
Gli algoritmi quantistici adottano un nuovo approccio a
questo tipo di problemi, sfruttando
le caratteristiche uniche della fisica quantistica come
la sovrapposizione, l'interferenza e l'entanglement.
I computer classici rimangono bloccati
nell'esplorazione di certe aree dello spazio computazionale,
quindi non riescono a trovare questi pattern.
I computer quantistici sono dotati di
capacità aggiuntive o prestazioni aumentate
per alcuni problemi, rese possibili dalla loro natura quantistica.
Per comprendere appieno il potenziale dei computer quantistici
è necessario addentrarsi nella teoria della complessità computazionale,
un ramo dell'informatica che si concentra su
misurare e confrontare lo sforzo computazionale necessario
per risolvere diversi tipi di problemi.
Questo fornisce un quadro di riferimento utile
per descrivere i vari speedup
e le classi di problemi che si incontrano nel
calcolo.